welcome back to growing my grandpa the
lovely game where you got lovely images
that will stick with you tonight when
you try to go to sleep like this and
this and this that's Grandpa we're
growing Grandpa I'm gonna end the week I
think I've done everything
I'm pretty sure and I can unsave if I if
I didn't I think batteries blueberries
fiberglass cashews lettuce banana
concealed battery dull Grandpa glue blah
blah mom
I got the picture of the mom that was
when I got the key then well I made
Grandpa puke and then I got the key and
then I got the mom picture now as you
acquired is giving you access new and
new conversation language all right
and that's it there's nothing else okay
good
to know but um
is this still I'll make believer is this
real Mrs Richards approached me the
other day in order to remark on Adrian's
development she noted how much more at
ease she appeared when called upon in
class or when asked to participate in
group exercises I told her I'd seen this
change happening as well and then as
much as I would like to take credit for
it I can only guess dimly at what might
be reshaping her attitude Ms Richards
posited that it was perhaps Adrian's
family moving into their grandfather's
property that caused the change it
apparently is out in the country in a
wooded area full of wide open space and
far from the bustle and noise of the
city
then how is she getting to school
the grandfather Dr Jacob Hart
interesting had jointly purchased the
land with the university he was employed
with and began constructing what he
intended to be a satellite campus for a
burgeoning psychological anthropology
program he had a hand in establishing
only one building ever ended up being
instructed after Dr Hart died in a car
accident when driving back from the
property one day yearly at almost the
exact same time a grad student who was
assisting Dr Hart on some sort of
project at the property vanished Without
a Trace
who the thunk the property sat in disuse
for years as it was tied up in legal
battles between Dr Hart's next of kin
the university the vanish grad students
family and the other students Dr Hart
was working with eventually the case was
settled out of court only recently did
the property fall into the possession of
Adrian's mother obviously I was not
going to relay this whole tragic story
to Adrian who for all I know believes
her Grandpa to still be living in the
basement of his home besides I thought
she might already know all of this
perhaps the elaborate story she was
constructing was her own way of Escaping
The Morbid details of a life or perhaps
lives cut short by cruel fate the cruel
force of facing the cynical adults who
squabbled in the aftermath I determined
perhaps the storytelling she was and
continues to engage in should not be
encouraged by me at least not in the way
I went about it before where I made
active inquiries into a strange fantasy
of a semi-sentient ball of skin
when I saw Adrian I did not bring up her
Grandpa or ask questions about his
growth Adrian could not stop talking
about it however I had no choice but to
weather her bizarre and enthusiastic
effusions about her new best friend
Adrian maybe we can talk about something
else I'm not sure why I'm following you
exactly he's he's so big he has so many
whiskers that come out and I can see
them move around when I think about him
I'm not sure what you mean I'm so happy
grandpa is back he's so much cooler than
Mom and Dad
once again for what it's worth I have
put down the story she told me as best
as I could
Adrian once again told me about growing
her Grandpa
great
thing before is still gone yes it is
oh man an ear
kiwi
all right
all clean good I still don't have
anything to cut this bulbous sack but I
will don't you worry about it I will
space will not be dirty again until next
week oh God not this
foreign
okay not a whole lot Grandpa
not a lot going on here so I think about
that painting looks strange
yeah you right
yeah you're right
potato
that's nice
oh life
good
indecision that's a big word for Grandpa
I don't know if Grandpa's gonna be able
to do that
clean
all this growth
oh good another bulbasack if only I had
something to cut it with all right
Grampy how are you doing hey is your
favorite granddaughter son
I think I'm okay I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to go back and do anything
oh
pear nice
I don't know who's putting stuff in the
fridge but these are awfully nice
okay
all right I've got fiberglass and uh
uh potato
[Music]
all right let's see if uh Grampy will
eat it and puke some
how
[Music]
hi Grandpa the gums are bleeding
slightly and its skin seems overly dry
it may need a food packed with vitamin c
a kiwi fruit fruit would be an excellent
remedy
uh-huh how do you know that
uh
uh
there you go oh no
oh indigestion I don't know if I should
be doing this but I feel like this is
the only way to get new materials
because I went through the whole
basement already and there really wasn't
anything there
oh good bulb is gross your time has come
get ready to die Bobo's
you make the incision within the girls
with your scissors
great it's not possible to look inside
appear inside the small opening in the
oily cavity a powerful smell of water
rises in many small increate beings lay
motionless and dead however you just
barely hear something near silence
slithering or something
or maybe it's just your imagination oh
good
oh no oh
no
[Music]
oh God okay
anthropoid Remnant won a self-sufficient
animal form knit together from years of
ambient thoughts left to crawl around
the basement Grandpa may enjoy the flesh
I don't know if I should do that is that
a face is that a face how many faces do
you see Lexi and run a pole or uh Marcus
Rachel everyone chip in here
[Music]
Little Friends
little friend
hey
[Music]
all right
bulbous Grove
[Music]
imagination that's for sure
oh there it is
anthropoid Remnant too okay good so I'm
gonna feed Grandpa and Grandpa's gonna
like it it said that Grandpa needed a
kiwi fruit I happen to have a kiwi and
it's a good thing I didn't put that
unappealing item in the Kiwi because
that would have been bad so from now on
I'm going to observe grandpa first so I
know the needs before I do anything
stupid
kiwi you'll like it
[Music]
how would you like an anthropoid
and it's silly a wave in a frenzy there
you go
I'm sure that's good
I'm sure no one's gonna be
upset about that the male appears to
have been particularly well see if
you're offering a flushed or something
within Grandpa from within the full div
of his body a wiry probuscus life
attendance begins to emerge it may be
worth taking a look at this after the
feeding knowledge you've gained
proboscis
aha
[Music]
good
content and ready to cooperate oh boy
[Music]
hi Grampy
okay
language
still struggles to somewhat speak due to
its underdeveloped tongue mouth and jaw
however it managed to rasp out and
answer grandpa is old my lives were
easier before I made myself to speak and
before you make clothes to wear and
rules to obey your grandpa remembers I
have learned much in many lives and
deaths keep speaking with me I love
talking with you and learning from you
and it helps your grandpa so much soon I
will be everything you would like me to
be
Little Friends Grandpa still struggles
someone to speak due to its under the
developed tongue with the little ones
they grew like seeds off my skin worms
fall off my body thoughts falling off of
me dreams put there by others when I was
under the ground I made only very few
Shepherds walked through the grave and I
saw them lusting for their wives and my
skin made their loving faces what
what
I called them out into the darkness with
their loved voices one by one I took
their shapes in their skin and blood
what
that was a time ago before Stone
buildings before the orders of angels
and words and symbols I'm sorry grandpa
is thinking but there's a little left
over from others too I'm still so hungry
for flesh part of me is I would even eat
one of them that fell off of me I can't
help it they grow off of me they fall
off and grow in the dark grow around me
okay well what about your proboscis
what about it
yes that is a part like a tongue I was
lost in the mountains and so thirsty I
was walking up a hill and found a lamb
and drank from it with my tongue and I
fell asleep for a long time I woke up as
a half-formed child I had died before my
grieving mother had remade me we had
made a contract and she completed it I
do not remember more
uh bye-bye
let's let's learn some language
life
life life
deep within Grandpa strange membranes
phonatecon
sure
it's close enough
oh that week three of growth 24 whiskers
appeared to recall some information from
a previous growth cycle we cannot be
sure that this was really the case for
all we know what we interpreted as it
were recollecting this information was
really a drawing semantic contact from
one of our Recollections of it and
redeploying it without rationality or
contextualization
for the sake of our safety and for the
sake of scientific inquiry we are
attempting to draw out from whiskers
whether it somehow retains Knowledge
from previous Cycles in its morphologic
nucleus we did not think it was possible
the nucleus though complex and
incredible in its regenerative abilities
was capable of this and that the nerve
Network That Grew From it made up the
base of whiskers mind and so we are now
attempting to ask whiskers as best we
can if it ever ever died or what am I
remember if it did
great
Grandpa's proboscis is out
good grandpa put your proboscis away
if you could put your proboscis back
that'd be good
examine
is Grandpa some words and the topics of
clothing and here in indecency we're
doing it Grandpa we're doing it
we're doing it Grandma we're doing it
you're doing it I'm proud of you
oh that's good
we are introducing the latest growth of
whiskers to more subtle social cues and
testing its ability to judge mental
states of participants in conversation
the semantic content that flows to
whiskers via its scifield is still
becoming muddled and slipped without
distinction into conversation although
Our intention of instilling in a solid
theory of mind will perhaps make it
begin to understand that we do not know
what it knows or know what we are
sending it
one would think a theory of mind seems
to develop as part of its maturing
process in order to hunt Sapient beings
it must be able to deceive them in order
to deceive it must be able to make
certain metacognitive judgments for
example if their deception appears to be
working or how one ought to be deceived
we may never see it develop a theory of
Mind anytime soon as Dr Hart has
disallowed a cycle of whiskers growth to
live into the beginnings of maturity
probably for the best I'm gonna say
that's a good idea Grandpa your
probuscus is still out I don't like that
I don't like that at all now my question
is should I feed it the other little
dude now or save it until next week
because honestly we should probably
ration these things out but then again
oh I know I do still have some of the
stuff that I had from last time like
this lettuce is still from last time
technically speaking
it would be greedy to give it all here
all right I'm gonna look at your
proboscis Grampy I'm not happy about it
you most in the grandpa to approach and
point to the thin protuberance
Grandpa's Island ex fully extends it
towards you
a minuscule needle extends from its tip
there appears to be one more thing you
must give if only for the sake of
propriety
and what's that
what is that
glue you want some glue
oh boy that was a bad idea wasn't it
grandpa has appreciated your blood
offering it will receive a symbol or
totem from you now although only one per
offering what as the blood fed probuscus
retracts back into the folds of fabric
you step away from the bars I'm not
happy that I did that I'm not happy that
I did that at all
I am really upset that that occurred
Grandpa please put your Probus guess
away what is a totem what do you mean by
a totem do you mean
mom doll
is that what you mean
this boy you talking about
Grampy I don't know what I'm doing and I
don't know why I'm doing it off her
mother doll here you go
oh hold out the mother symbol you
created Great Grandpa's spines quickly
reach out and envelop the doll before
drawing back the doll quickly vanishes
within the fold of Grandpa's skin
constructing and then offering your
mother's image to Grandpa symbolically
stated by blood instills in you a
concrete sense of completion Grandpa
gives us off affirming grunt as it
senses deep with a soft affirming as it
senses deep within your mind the ritual
transformation of your desire although
Grandpa must receive both a mother and
father totem before the Fulfillment of
your wish is assured
yeah
yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah so what I'm gonna do if I had to
think about this super rationally
because I gotta save some of this good
stuff I gotta save the good stuff for
next time because the only thing that I
have here left over is uh that place I
can't see and all of this is done oh no
way wait no is it an unlimited amount
you said that I thought this was done
for
that's what I thought okay that's what I
thought I just was able to clear him out
again because you know that's how it is
okay okay I'm gonna I'm gonna feed
grandpa again but I again I'm not gonna
feed the the the food I'll feed the
strawberry
neutral what about the pear
thank you
lettuce
lettuce
[Music]
all right good all Fed Up
okay all good thank you
yep
uh-huh
aha
good week week four
the time I have spent compiling an
evaluation of Adrian is almost up and I
still can't say what to make it for
changes in mood it is of course a case
of children of Adrian's age are nowhere
near finished learning and growing I may
have to simply be happy that Adrian was
able to improve her attitude however
something in the audit and occasionally
grotesque's story she continues to bring
up and still strike me as meaningful
how has your week been Adrian grandpa is
almost ready he's almost finished well
sort of ah he's almost as big as his
shell now he has a face and he can talk
pretty well and almost has legs I see as
before I have put down the story she
told me as best I could once again
Adrian told me about growing your
grandpa I sure did let me check on
grandpa first hey
foreign
oh no you examined Grandpa Grandpa seems
fatigued in an almost anemic some of its
spines appear brittle perhaps it would
be more Cooperative if fed a rich iron
rich meal like meat
all right meat it is you got it um
done it
Don't You Worry About a Thing kitchen we
got an apple that's good
we got uh Jackfruit that sounds pretty
good
all right let's see what else is here
I think from before is gone I'm sure it
is
our soap
hi
nope no more here
I think it might be good that I saved it
I have a feeling anyway
meaning
good
oh bulbas growth
oh good oh Mama's growth oh good bulb is
growth oh good
[Music]
oh there it is okay I got it anthropoid
three
do I need three
hey flatbread
getting a lot of food here
something tells me maybe I shouldn't
have ever fed it like things like meat
things or the little meat dudes but
it said no no animal meat maybe maybe
this is fine though I'm thinking this
might be fine how else would I have
gotten the proboscis a mushroom oh the
Gorman grind I did it symbol great okay
all right Grampy I got everything I
think I think I do I'm just gonna save
imma call it a day I'm gonna prepare you
oh you're gonna get a pair and a bar of
soap bam conceal
there we go this is uh how long is it
how many how is this gonna yeah
[Music]
you don't be standing please
oh God no
hi
hmm
[Music]
yep okay Grandpa stomach contents oh
good
that was in Grandpa
he's saving them
oh look at this girl man great stuff
simple paper doll
wow Classics of alchemy on the virtue of
the brilliant when dealing with Devils
these splendors and Terrors of God's
creation inhabit the world they're both
seen and unseen and just as one will not
grapple with the LIE unless they be a
fool one will not approach him being of
a mind or Aether without foreknowledge
thereof I don't know what any of this
means but there are still more beings
which travel the Realms only by God's
grace and his angels serving crushing
these beings under heal managers
to devour them being in their nature
devil is part of a contract only
requires a token of these givings that
is a symbol
the devil hungers after flesh and would
strip a man to his bones in the
devouring the devil's hunger in nature
which thirst for flesh can be yelled in
a beings in the ritual act of giving
blood in only a few drops however the
contract must be completed in full for
if the magician airs and does not
provide in the devil instruction and
guidance the devil once objured to do no
harm upon the magician will return to
its devouring nature
okay whatever that means
I'm unsure
ah wait a minute I wrote this down three
two three two four five uh
hello
oh
a young photo of your father as a young
man he was a goddamn hippie he was a
goddamn hippie is that what you're
telling me
fine
well glued those together and now it's
time to feed Grandpa some more so his
protuberance
you know
that whole deal is a proboscis hey
Grandpa you're real tall Grampy Grandpa
you're real tall dad I don't like it how
about an anthropoid
there you go
there it is it's proboscius
good so it was right to ration the
[Music]
content and ready to cooperate
examining proboscis
oh boy
how
okay you want the father doll
you want you like the Father the little
birdie you like the doll softer firming
grunt
completed contract
that sounds good uh maybe
yeah
oh boy
though still not fully formed is
revealed oh
oh
no what if I can can it talk more about
these
ah you're asking me about your wish oh
good when you wish for me to come back
that's when I knew I would your
desperation was strong and your wish for
your parents well if you give me what I
want I'll give you what you want you
know I love you I am for you whatever
you want and I love you just as much as
you love me but desperation and love is
not enough people deep down know they
can't get what they wish for without
some transformation there is something
that sits at the root of everyone's soul
that understands the separation between
them and Eternity you may desire
something but you know you will not get
it without some movement on your part so
it is not enough to just wish which you
will know will not work you must wish in
a little more to transform your
intention into something that might [ __ ]
fructify or for desire to become reality
your language is
good shell ah you're asking me about my
shell oh well you see I like to have
something to grow in something shaped
like a person it just helps to have
something surrounding me when I don't
have skin my whiskers do the growing my
whiskers yes you know the hairy little
things I am a part of it and it is a
part of me however my whiskers are what
hurts you wishing for me to come back
and so they went to work in the Shell
you provided the shell also helps you
envision me as what you desire you have
such a nice imagination if I weren't in
my shell you'd have my whiskers exposed
and knitting together my face that might
interrupt the feedback loop of my
reading your desires and then acting
upon the desires I have read and then
once again reading your hairy action we
wouldn't want that interfered with the
material of the doll you put down his
good fit it is not the most comfortable
but is quite flexible and thankfully my
shell was able to adjust nicely to my
growth
foreign
part of burnt up dying self into the bin
they often forgot what the code was and
I had to go check on the wall I already
know it okay I remember seeing a man
that looked quite like me his daughter
had given him a photo of her new
boyfriend he threw it into the bin in
disgust ah I know it's there I already
know
language the more you taught me the more
I was able to learn Myself by hearing
what you're thinking and saying a week
ago I could speak a little bit but I was
less of what you imagined me to be and
not quite the talker I am at the moment
part of what I'm saying is of course
made up of what you expect me to say I
think I'm very comfortable with being
open and honest with you because I'm
your grandpa and I love you and
certainly that makes me part of Mexico
part of what I am however there's a part
deeper down the thing that created me
baby that undying nucleus it is
answering for me as well and is
unaffected by whoever might shape what I
become with their thoughts
great uh Little Friends well yes they
come for me
um
think of them like dreams have you ever
had a dream that was sort of like a
bunch of people places and events you
experience all mixed up and jumbled up
sort of threading through and disposing
of the refuse of the mind my little
friends are like that refuse and
enridding myself of them I am casting
off the excess material I did not use in
developing life forms anyone who comes
close to me well there are my eyes my
nose my skin their thoughts become mine
and shape what I make however when I was
alone for so long I didn't have a lot of
people near me what are you thinking and
expecting of me is shaping what I'm
saying how I'm saying do you understand
and so because I did not have enough
input from my surroundings in order to
put material to use the material falls
off my body crawls away and usually dies
I am able to make the most of my
material when someone is looking right
at me projecting who I will be like you
are now what you are thinking and
expecting of me is shaping what I'm
saying I'm saying it do you understand
no I do but I don't oh my Provost is a
little tube I keep to help feed me I'm
blood you could say it's my real mouth
but it's not really a mouth it only
appeared because you fed me flesh one of
those little friends you found I think
you feeding me flesh was a simple a
proposition if you will that you wanted
to hold up your end of the bargain with
regards to your wish if someone is
willing to hold up their end to the
bargain and let me feed on them with my
probuscus then they can move on to the
next step of the agreement providing me
symbolic instructions I hope that clears
up things oh do you have another
question do I like the blood well my
whiskers I believe they like the blood
and the flesh it's strange they are me
and yet they are I'm guessing that's
subie not me I am bound to them they
control me and technically yes they did
make me however you were the one who
really grew me in some ways those
whiskers they are me or a part of myself
or I am a part of it that part is much
more animal-like whatever might happen
no I will always love you and because it
controls me I might not be able to act
how I would like even if I do love you
[Music]
oh well that is not good completed
contracts thank you so much for
completing the contract I'll definitely
help you out with your parents just give
me a little time and I'll be ready to
act I think you'll be very happy your
grandpa is very happy too you did it all
by yourself you know I couldn't have
helped you if I tried I would have
really not have liked to well
I did not want you to not complete the
contract I would have hated that but do
you understand why I would have had to
maybe you don't so much of your lives
are made up and yet what comes to pass
was always once a fiction you doubt
yourself and your plans even before they
begin and you believe what is in front
of you as if the essence of things was
not something you put there long ago
too much doubt can suffocate even the
surest thing only with patience and
growth to nurturing does something
become what it will be as you see you
soon Chelsea
okay
yep
let's learn meaning
[Music]
you got it
we further delve into the abstraction
with whiskers partially or perhaps for
the most part for the purpose of
determining the origin of its
recollection that preceded its death
Dr Hart has begun to theorize that in
the process of death the structure of
whiskers is compressed back into the
morphologic nucleus and then later upon
re-establishing the nerve and netting
that is laced through its spines is
slowly reassembled and deployed as
needed I do not think this is the case
for I can plainly see that for the
growth cycles in which whiskers is not
receiving our pronunciation and
vocabulary lessons at its capacity
general for comprehending its
environment is greatly diminished and in
the simulated conversations we carry out
whiskers struggles greatly or else does
not participate in any case we will
press on with our lessons and heed Dr
Hart's caution regarding terminating the
growth cycle before whiskers allotted
growth time passes or if it appears to
be becoming just a little too competent
at appearing human
I agree kind of I think I don't know it
seems like uh what you did might have
gotten y'all killed so I don't know
I don't know
please
good
there appears to be nothing written here
if there was it was thoroughly erased
well
can't help that well it's time to feed
Grampy Gramps and then uh yep let me
just see which one I need to save the
Apple so don't feed the Apple got it
okay
Justin hi Grandpa you can sit down you
look like that Resident Evil thing that
is definitely there you go you kill me
definitely
okay so strawberry
palatable flatbread
[Music]
okay we're all good here
we're all good let's end the week yep
I feel good about what I did
yep subordination of hidden being yep
yep okay I met with Adrian one final
time in order to see if I could now
reach some sort of resolution regarding
her emotional trouble in these past few
weeks according to the reports of her
teachers and peers she has shown a
remarkable transformation and conduct I
would also add my voice to this
consensus it seems as if our time
together much has changed for the better
I'm not suggesting our meetings were the
sole source of her sea change I think
something has happened in her home life
that is reoriented to Adrian completely
she seems to suggest as much at least in
her usual esoteric way when the last we
spoke
something tells me something may have
changed with Grandpa yes but
I will write down her words verbatim
here I went down the stairs like I
always did but I sort of felt like
something was different my parents
weren't arguing and I felt that
something had changed with Grandpa there
was a weird noise but I wasn't afraid
Grandpa
oh my God
oh
[Music]
I think my grandpa had to leave but
before he left he made my parents nice
he reached inside and changed them that
was my wish
maybe even what I was growing wasn't
really my grandpa grandpa left what I
was growing behind
he's gone now
he moved quickly out to I don't know
where but I'll always love him
I dismissed Adrian soon after letting
her know it was a pleasure getting to
know her
despite my apprehensiveness about the
speed of the turnaround she has made I
cannot see any reason why Adrian should
be considered for further evaluation
and as a counselor for Adrian let it be
known I believe she is of sound but
gentle and emotional health
hey please if these things have turned
out to the land if I made Mega breathing
in them
but I happen since Mrs Richardson bumped
into the heart family the other day
while running an errand she told me the
Bears were a little odd but very
pleasant and quite clearly they adored
their child
I thought she had never seen Adrian
Javier
they're two endings
development of patreon
games
well
that was growing my grandpa I'm pretty
sure that was bad and I'm pretty sure
the other ending's probably an ending of
death and oh but I'm sure it's all bad
that's the thing about Cosmic body
Horrors that it's usually all bad so
thank you James for making growing my
grandpa I enjoyed this very much so I've
got to curious where uh discover our
bodies is because if I remember discover
my body
that was many years ago not that this
wasn't great I just hope that game's
coming
out
coming out all this crazy body order
stuff is great I love it it's disturbing
it makes me extremely uncomfortable
thank you also there's a link in the
description if you want to cheer up
after this one I'll listen to a round of
distractible it's right there in the
description below me Bob and Wade having
a good time also check out raft we
started that back up and we'll be doing
more very soon thank you
A Farewell see you next one
bye-bye
[Music]